I realize everyone else I am like
everyone else I'm just a regular normal
guy just my wife doesn't appreciate her
understand that she won't done the C
thinks I'm special but I'm just a
regular guy do you think your husband is
a regular guy no no way he's he's very
creative person and he comes up with all
these really wacky ideas okay and his
grandkids call him silly because he's
always saying funny and silly face
Highschool if you remember what made you
feel that way all my friends started
drinking and smoking and getting into
things and I was just thought into it
and that's around the time I found
hardcore music and I realized that being
clean from drug and alcohol is something
that's strong within hardcore scene and
I found straightedge and that's when I
realized kind of different from
a lot of people would similar to a lot
as well
okay I think I realized I was not like
everyone else as soon as I realized that
there were other people so like as far
back as I can remember and I'm exactly
why but
I guess I just always felt like it was
hard to find just the right place to fit
in where there were other people like me
but
probably elementary school because I
grew up in a super small town in the
middle of nowhere Texas with about 50
kids and clearly I don't look normal and
so I was not like anyone else I knew and
used to think it was a bad thing and
then as I grew up I grew into it
but I think it's kind of always been
that way
I got nominated to be like the weirdest
person on this boat troop this one time
actually and they nominated me because I
used to eat pears with ranch like I
thought too gross now but um so I got to
touch like the booger of a lobster which
is their antenna things they're actually
like their nose and so that was kind of
cool and I was like okay cool if you are
weird sometimes you get to do weird [ __ ]
it's fun I think that everything
and what makes you feel that
[Music]
during my second year in the United
States like 2015
and do you remember what made you feel
that way yeah a when I helped people but
[Music]
like they kept asking more and more and
more but never like Nam never but when I
asked for help
sometimes they didn't so I felt upset
and
and most of that most of the time people
didn't like encourage me they always
like pull me back and
no it's a real world it's not like
Disneyland remember what setting you
were in was this at work at school yeah
school cuz I just graduated okay yeah
I'm in high school when they not believe
me but they did jokes about my curly
hair because inserts and not a lot of
people are curly hairs so I think that I
noticed that I'm not than everyone else
because I'm a special hair I think I
always knew that I mean I grew up with
mostly like white people and I was
always a darkest one so I always felt
kind of outcast mood by that you know
they come for more money
from less but I mean never really
bothered me
about ten years ago
probably about 10 years ago you might
have question do you remember what
specifically or generally made you feel
that way there's a lot of things
actually yeah I'm 37 years old I have
six children and there's hardly anyone
like me like that I travel the world for
a living so yeah and definitely not like
everyone else
well younger and just got into an
argument with a girl who didn't like the
same thing I was like okay I'm different
[Music]
because I was into a different type of
guys than the girls I was any allegory
yeah
I realize one like like when I'm live
like your group of people and notice
that I stood out because like everybody
was laughing and joking together and I
just couldn't like to see the humor
behind it or my humor wasn't the same as
theirs cause when I thought like man I'm
not like him so I was like
I wasn't making middle school yeah you
still feel that way today yeah
definitely when I came to study to the
u.s. in Psych you know I didn't know
English and I don't know anything from
like the culture here so I had to learn
everything and people kind of like I
mean I got bullied a little bit but like
some of my yeah so I was like when I was
like 10
[Music]
I guess that's a hard question because
being unique is like the cool thing to
do right now
and so everyone trying to be unique
makes you look like everybody else so
it's kind of hard to be not like
everyone else nowadays especially good
Instagram and Facebook it's so known to
everyone for me if you're cool you're
actually not that cool I guess that's my
answer I'm not I guess I am kind of like
everyone else probably when I realized I
started picking up on the propaganda and
the media more when I was a kid I like
seeing it mixed in with like religion
and everything else and you just you
could realize but you know you'd be
alive through it everybody's sitting on
like here like I'll believe this for
real it's like nah like not as stuff as
I saw joke I like I can't believe people
fall for this and then that's when I
started to realize it like if you aren't
paying attention stuff's going on
when people kept telling me you don't
belong here you don't you don't know how
to actually talk to people you not like
everyone else that kind of made me feel
like I'm not like other people but I
could be different in a good way
just last week in my child development
class that I attend at college and they
were talking about how adolescents go
through mood swings but that they are
usually done by like 18 years old and
I'm definitely still going through
dramatic mood swings that was probably
one when I was born because I was a big
baby so I was 9 pounds 12 ounces now I
was born in Ohio in a real small town
and when I registered for school that
year I got to have my picture in the
newspaper because I was the smallest
child to ever register for school it was
a slow news day I only weighed like 40
pounds or something like that I was just
very petite very tiny
I said it was a small town and you could
get anything in the paper so you unique
for you that's great especially the
difference in her Heights
she's TG and I'm Big Daddy Peregrine
kids
[Music]
I guess I'm still seeing you know what
sort of basis that is really founded on
and if that's like a if that's just my
interpretation that I am different than
anybody else but I can't remember
exactly when probably after college I
went to LSU in Baton Rouge
you know the whole time you're there
you're probably trying to fit in with
everyone else but
you know at the end of my tenure there
in college I think I realized it that's
not really what it's about
do you remember what specifically made
me feel that way
not really no I would have to say just
you know you kind of feel like you fight
it for a while and then then one day you
realize that what's the point
I wasn't born with a sense of smell yeah
so my cousins would ask me to smell
things I was lie to them and be like oh
it smells good like I would wait for the
reactions but yeah I still can't smell
to this day so first off that is the
best question I would say when I was
three and my that's probably my first
memory I ever had and I feel like I just
knew that day it was just like the
beginning of my growth and you remember
what exactly made you feel that way
no I just have this like image in my
head and I like to paint and so a lot of
times people ask me you know to explain
the painting and I can't it's more just
a feeling so in my head is just this
memory in this image and I'm down and
I'm just looking up and I'm like that's
like my first memory that's like the
first thing I remember and then I've
started from there
[Music]
I don't know if I've ever realized I
don't know why would you say that
I'm not sure I think everyone's watching
them what's up guys my name is Raya and
I'm the owner of this channel I'm also
the person behind the camera and I
thought I'd take a minute to thank all
the subscribers I gained so far and
maybe ask the new years to hit the
subscribe button if you liked this
episode or if you're a fan of my channel
in general I mean a lot
thank you